déjà deux ans que virginie honorât de
martin son mari et leurs trois enfants
ont quitté bordeaux en france pour
s'installer dans les basses laurentides
ils détiennent un permis travail qui
viennent à échéance en mai on arrivait
pour changer de vie pour trouver du
travail pour offrir un environnement
économique favorable pour l'avenir de
nos enfants
la famille a entamé des procédures pour
demeurer au québec pour de bon d'abord
avec une demande de certificat de
sélection du québec fait en ou 2017 et
une demande au programme d'expérience
québécoise déposée en janvier
j'ai eu le mandat du premier ministre de
corriger la situation
mais depuis que québec a annoncé qu'il
compte annuler les dix huit mille
dossiers d'immigration non traités
c'est la panique c'est très stressant ce
qu'en plus on est propriétaire on a
acheté notre maison on a vraiment le don
restait on a investi
et l'on sait pas si on va être obligé de
rentrer pour revenir si on va pouvoir
rester entre deux virginie on aura de
martin a contacté le ministère de
l'immigration qui n'a pas été en mesure
de faire la lumière sur le dossier de sa
famille
québec remboursera les demandeurs pour
les droits exigibles qu'ils ont déboursé
rien qui ne fait le bonheur de
l'ingénieur h&m bensalem dans la tente
d'un statut depuis 2017 et les tests de
français 400 dollars qui va rembourser
le temps qui va rembourser le stress qui
va rembourser les offres de travail
qu'on a refusé qui va rembourser en
angleterre en allemagne en france de
l'algérie
mohamed benelhadj et choqué il a entamé
des démarches d'immigration en 2015
je prévois de de porter plainte déjà je
suis dans un groupe sur facebook
je peux vous dire que tout le monde est
prêt
politique le ministre de l'immigration
affirme que les demandeurs pourront
recommencer le processus
on annonce aussi qu on réduit les délais
d'attentes de 36 à 6 mois donc on coupe
de 30 mo les délais pour traiter
beaucoup plus rapidement des paroles peu
rassurante pour des milliers de gens
dont l'avenir demeure incertain
ici valérie niquet et l'abeille radio
canada montréal